we're going on the private jets we're
going on the private jets tell me to
off one more time I'm taking your
phone away yeah try acquiring a tech
company without your phone good luck
watch your mouth cursing like a bunch of
sailors and you can kiss your Xbox
goodbye
might I suggest the next company Retreat
is a cruise to Bermuda all you can eat
breakfast buffet
okay hear me out I become CEO come on no
come on did she just call me a slime
puppy I'm gonna use that on my husband
I have no idea what Roman is ever saying
to me it's like he's speaking in tongues
and also Shakespeare why do you keep
asking me what's the temperature I'm in
menopause I have no idea what is this
I'm locked out of my email can anyone
help me did you stop calling each other
names please your siblings all right
you're all each other's got one day I'm
not going to be here anymore
and then what I just got this blazer
with my Kohl's cash now Kohl's cash is
not crypto